vamos a empezar este vídeo suponiendo
que estamos trabajando en un espacio de
tres dimensiones de todo el mundo
conocemos muy bien un espacio de tres
dimensiones porque esencialmente es
donde nosotros vivimos donde nosotros
caminamos y bueno vamos a suponer que en
este espacio de tres dimensiones tengo
yo un fluido puede ser el fluido que tú
quieras el que prefieras imaginarte
puede ser agua puede ser aire puede ser
aceite puede ser chapopote puede ser lo
que tú quieras el punto es que sea un
fluido y esté fluido pues sobre todo
tiene una característica que es la
densidad y tiene una densidad definida
en cada punto de este espacio porque
podría ser que el fluido no sea uniforme
pues no sé a lo mejor es más denso en
algunos lados que en otros entonces esta
función ro que es la función de densidad
de masa esencialmente me está diciendo
cuál es la densidad del fluido en cada
punto del espacio ok y a lo mejor ese
fluido no solo está ahí no está estático
quizás se está moviendo y por lo tanto
tiene una velocidad
a punto del espacio ok otra vez está
definido no de forma digamos homogénea
porque a lo mejor ese fluido va más
rápido en algunos lados que en otros a
lo mejor podríamos pensar que en algunos
lados está obstruido o quién sabe y le
ponemos un gorrito porque apunta en
cierta dirección es decir le ponemos una
flechita porque esto es un vector y la
velocidad es un vector te está diciendo
hacia dónde se está dirigiendo y con qué
con qué rapidez entonces vamos a definir
esta función nueva que se va a llamar
efe y le voy a poner gorrito porque
esencialmente f la estoy definiendo como
la densidad por la velocidad
ok entonces la densidad es un es un
escalar
es un número real mientras que la
velocidad es un vector por lo tanto f si
resulta de ser la multiplicación de un
escalar por un vector pues es un vector
entonces quizás ya te estás acordando de
que es lo que hacíamos en las integrales
dobles
nada más estamos extendiendo este
concepto a tres dimensiones efe es la
multiplicación de la densidad por la
velocidad si ya conoces un poquito de la
física pues sabrás que esto podría
llamarse también el momento un momento
de densidad si quieres verlo de esa
forma pero bueno si no lo has visto o
suena muy raro para ti solo espera un
poco y vamos a ver qué significa esto
entonces supongamos ahora que quiero
calcular la integral vamos a calcular
una integral de esta de ésta efe
ok df que multiplica que hace un
producto con el vector unitario normal a
la superficie ok entonces queremos
calcular esta integral de superficie
ahora es decir estamos sumando esta
cantidad del momento angular estamos
sumando lo a lola
perdón no quise decir angular quise
decir de densidad estamos sumando toda
esta esta está este momento de densidad
a lo largo de una superficie entonces
vamos a pintar esta superficie
y ahí está
nuestra superficie
creo que me pasé un poco vamos a
corregirle aquí y vamos a pintarlo en un
espacio tridimensional es decir vamos a
pintar nuestros ejes ahí está uno de los
ejes digamos que baja hasta acá
y acá está el otro de los ejes sale por
aquí y aquí está el tercero de los ejes
entonces este es el eje z este es el eje
x y este es el eje y y esta es mi
superficie entonces vamos a ver qué
significa esto por ejemplo la de ese
quién es de ese pues va a ser
esencialmente un parchecito aquí este es
de s ok
esta es nuestra perdón esta es nuestra
diferencial esta es un área de
esencialmente un parche muy pequeño y
vamos a pintar también la n aquí anda n
quien es n pues es un vector que es
normal es decir es ortogonal a la
superficie ok y que además tiene una
norma unitaria es decir su tamaño es de
1 y finalmente la f la f es una función
que está definida en todos lados de este
espacio a lo mejor en este punto define
un vector así acá define otro así quién
sabe puede estar definido de formas muy
muy raras y muy locas pero el punto es
que f está definido también en la
superficie entonces por ejemplo aquí hay
un vector de que lo asigna él
la función f acá puede haber otro aquí
puede haber otro no sé entonces que
estamos haciendo cuando multiplicamos
efe punto n esto está midiendo
esencialmente la magnitud de f que
apunta en la dirección del vector normal
n o bien cuál es la magnitud de f en
dirección normal a la superficie cuando
decimos normal estamos pensando de forma
perpendicular o ortogonal ok entonces
quizás esto es muy raro puede puede
sonar un poco extraño pero vamos a hacer
por ejemplo que cuáles son las unidades
de esto si tomamos unidades de esto ya
es un poquito más claro por ejemplo la
de s sus unidades son metros cuadrados
por ejemplo no podrían ser centímetros
que sé yo lo vamos a decir que son
metros es decir estamos calculando un
área mientras que las unidades de f pues
es fijense es la densidad
la densidad pueden ser kilogramos sobre
metros cúbicos que multiplica la
velocidad que la velocidad no es otra
cosa más que metros sobre segundo
entonces los metros cúbicos se van con
metros cuadrados y con estos metros y
simplemente me queda que todo esto está
en kilogramos sobre sobre segundo todo
esto
ok entonces qué es esto esto me está
diciendo la cantidad de masa de este
fluido que sale en cada punto ok
esta está este cálculo digamos efe.es me
está diciendo en cada punto de la
superficie me calcular cuánta masa del
fluido está saliendo en ese punto ahora
que sí yo estoy sumando a lo largo de
toda esta superficie me está diciendo
que tanta masa de este fluido qué tanta
cantidad está saliendo a lo largo de
toda la superficie en un momento dado ok
entonces es por eso que a esta expresión
hacemos como el flujo el flujo a través
de una superficie de dos dimensiones
ok entonces es el flujo a través
el flujo a través de una superficie y
espero que el nombre sea bastante claro
a partir de lo que hemos dicho espero
que sea más conceptual y la superficie
está dada en dos dimensiones ok entonces
por ejemplo esto podría tener muchas
interpretaciones no por ejemplo qué tal
que tuviéramos un vapor de agua por
ejemplo cuando te estás bañando sale
mucho vapor salen gotitas de agua que
están saliendo porque el agua está
caliente qué sé yo y sobre todo esto es
más claro cuando tiene un rayo de luz
por ejemplo la luz del sol que entra a
través de la ventana y que las
partículas es más fácil de verlas no
entonces cada una de éstas tiene cierta
velocidad y dirección ok por ejemplo
esta se están moviendo aquí y cuando
calculamos el flujo por ejemplo a lo
mejor estamos pensando que si tenemos
una ventana
por ejemplo que aquí está
y esta ventana en realidad podríamos
pensar al flujo como que tanta masa de
estas gotitas de agua o de este vapor
está atravesando la ventana digo no es
que sea una superficie pero estamos
representando este rectángulo como una
superficie aunque la ventana es un
espacio vacío me explicó el detalle es
que si consideramos este rectángulo y
queremos ver qué tanto vapor de agua
está saliendo a través de eso pues
podríamos pensar en este concepto de
flujo otro otro ejemplo que podríamos
pensar es por ejemplo qué pasaría si
tuviéramos un río y solo sólo voy a
conceptualizar esto a lo mejor de forma
muy muy chistosa porque a lo mejor
digamos que tengo esta sección de río
que es este como un prisma digamos
aunque yo sé que el río no son prismas
pero es para que quede clara la idea
porque esencialmente cuando uno ve desde
arriba un río ve esta esta parte de
arriba esta es digamos que como esta
tapa de la del prisma entonces las
partículas de agua que van a lo largo
del río
llevan cierta dirección sí y vamos a
considerar por ejemplo que ahora nuestra
superficie es una es una malla o una red
que está aquí puesta en este en esta
sección del río y a lo largo de la cual
está cruzando el agua no digo la la red
no tiene que ser rectangular solo lo
hago así para que quede más claro qué es
lo que estamos haciendo entonces la
pregunta podría ser bueno qué tanta
cantidad de agua que tanta masa de esta
agua está cruzando la red en cada
momento dado ok entonces eso es
esencialmente lo que definimos como el
flujo a través de una superficie en dos
dimensiones y bueno espero que haya
quedado más claro todo esto que tengamos
algo más conceptual de lo que es el
flujo en el próximo vídeo
veremos cómo calcular esto y sobre todo
veremos cómo representarlo de diferentes
formas